those against the minute
those abstaining from the minutes
two abstentions at the back three three
is it okay three abstention thank you
very much indeed
uh announcements uh this is the last
scheduled full council meeting
uh before the next election so hopefully
uh I won't have to uh be in the hot seat
anymore until I perhaps hope to return
so we just leave it like that thank you
so it's item four now to the
Declarations of Interest
uh what members wish to record directly
declarations at the back over there
there's councilor Richard Dawes Richard
hi thanks um so uh in terms of
Declaration of Interest I I just like to
raise the Declaration of interest that I
uh had pointed out in uh in the summer
of last year and I've questioned twice
uh a nice clarification from the
monitoring officer he he suggested I had
a pecuniary interest and that that was a
criminal offense in terms of partaking
in the meeting I asked him at the last
full council meeting to put that in
writing he's refused to do so
um similarly uh in terms of Declarations
of interest uh at the last meeting
councilor patch put forward a
declaration of interest in the monetary
officer suggested he needed to put that
uh that request in two days prior to the
meeting that's not correct he didn't
hold the pecuniary interest in terms of
my interest uh you uh the monitoring
office referred to section 33 of the
local localism act but he actually meant
to refer to sex in 28 which allows the
council to widen the definition of
disclosable pecuniary interests for the
purpose of the council's own code of
conduct and that includes unpaid
directorships but it does not change the
definition in section 34 of the offenses
which is determined by section 30 which
states for this chapter a pecuniary
interest a disposable pecuniary interest
in relation to the person is if a
description in the regulation is made by
the Secretary of State and
if the interests of the person is
relevant to the regulation
the pecuniary interest which are
described in chapter 7 of part one of
the ACT are interest uh that are
specified in the column of the section
of these regulations the second column
does not include Mr Woodhead seems to
imagine that Council can change the
definition of the pecuniary interest and
create a new criminal offense the
attention of the the intentional
localism Act is the Crim to criminalize
certain actions which are real pecuniary
interests so I would like the monitoring
officer either to substantiate in
writing his definition of pecuniary
interest in the directorship I hold in
the not-for-profit Newton Abbott
Alexandra theater Community benefit
Society or issue a full and unreserved
apology thank you
thank you
thank you for the Declaration of
Interest as I see a direct Declaration
of interest you just declare what you've
you've you've your your interest you
believe to be and then you run the
gauntlet whether anybody makes a
complaint against you or not uh that's
as I say no doubt you'd want to respond
to me yes I will I will because I'm
writing a point of order and it's a very
clear defamation of my character to
suggest that I am conducting a criminal
act by uh undertaking uh partaking in a
in a meeting the monitoring officer
knows because he's been written to with
legal definitions that he's
misrepresenting those interests and he
continues to do so uh if he continues to
do so uh without correcting it I will
have to assume he's doing it with
malicious intent and that's a very
serious claim but I've asked him since
last June to retract and correct the
record I asked him one final time to
issue a full and unreserved apology
since you've noted it's the managing
director tells me that it's noted we've
noted your complaint so uh I'm going to
move on Richard uh from that councilor
McGregor
thank you chair um it was just a note
that on item seven I may have a
declaration of interest there I'm about
to become or to start my my role as
governor on the NHS
uh South Avenue 128 Foundation trust
which I note actually is missing from
the people that we should be writing to
on that motion but I will mention that
at the time
well I'm pleased I'm pleased you're here
today with all everything going on
because you're going to be our
representative of the trust what's
happening today is very important so
thank you for raising that Declaration
of interest and members of the public
you now know who are representative is
it's councilor McGregor on that point so
thank you very much for that Declaration
of of interest
um
so we move on to item five which is
public questions
are there any questions there are no
public questions no public questions
right I'm gonna at this point
um
change the order just took two items uh
as we've got so much interest here from
about timoth Hospital uh we we don't
want to take you through uh the whole of
our budget account you can you're very
welcome to stay but I'm going to switch
item seven around with item six
so we can have a a long and formed
debate about the budget without the
pressure of of keeping you all here and
trying to hurry the budget through uh
because of the fact you're waiting to
hear the timoth hospital item so we'll
take the returns item six around with
item seven so uh we go to item uh seven
which is of course the uh
recommendation from the executive of the
7th of February the notice of motion of
the closure of timmouth hospital so uh
you you've seen the what's on the agenda
and written what we intend to do uh
recommended to the chair items one two
three and four and I don't propose to
read that out so we'll go to councilor
connet who the leader to propose this
motion Alan
thank you chairman
um the executive considered it what I'm
going to do if I may just formally move
the recommendations allow others who I
know wish to speak and I reserve my
right to reply at the end to summate
thank you very much chairman
thank you very much
um I hope we have a unanimous Vote for
This motion today uh we will be taking
it to Devon County Council uh I would
like to pay tribute to the people who
have the people of timoth and air and
the surrounding Villages who have not
let this matter go and have kept the
fight good fight up and I think at last
we are seeing a glimmer of hope we're
not out of the woods yet but we are we
have a glimmer of hope
um it's not for reasons and I've
probably rehearsed this saying this
again is not for reasons of emotion or
tradition it's because Tim of hospital
has a clear medical need and it's ever
so obvious now that a third of patients
it's a terrible term it's a vile term
it's a victim blaming term of bed
blocking and this is causing massive
problems from the queues of ambulances
at the hospital and the answer is very
simple it's already there is already a
place in Tim of hospital that they heat
because they to keep the fabric of the
building we've got a wonderful League of
friends at timoth and that's where
sentiment and uh does cut does play a
role the community will rally round and
defend and help Tim of Hospital succeed
um
and it's the league of friends is
prepared to put money in uh to help save
timoth hospital and make it a place
um there is there's this room at Tim of
hospital for GPS there's room for
possibly dental and we are looking at
all the options but I mean we need to
save Tim of hospital
um I think it's already all been said
and uh I hope people will give this
motion a unanimous support thank you
thank you
it's like you again chair um
and thank you for moving this up the
agenda I think it's really important to
get this this heard one of the things
that I did notice when I was reading
through the notice of motion and the
recommendations was that um Torbay and
South Devon NHS Foundation trust CEO and
chair were missed off the list of people
to write to and I think I would like to
propose an amendment
that they are included in the round
robin of people to to write to
they're in number one sorry they're in
number one I'm told
I think
I think the CEO's not not included there
but thank you the chair
[Music]
it's recommended to full cancel that one
the council asked some managing
directors to write to the chairs and
chief Executives of the tour Bay and
South Carolina Trust Devon clinical
commissioning group The relevant members
of parliament and the Secretary of State
for health asking for a review of the
hospital closure plans mindful of the
pressures on local acute hospitals
through delayed discharges to other
appropriate provision and then it goes
on chairman the council contact the
chair of Devon County council's Health
and adult social care scrutiny committee
councilor Randall Johnson requesting the
committee rights of a secretary's state
for Health and Social care to answer a
review of the planned closure of timoth
Hospital three the overview in scrutiny
committee that's team Bridges to
consider undertaking review of the
closure of cottage hospitals in the
district and for the council right to
the chair of the integrated care system
for Devon
Dr Wollaston and the chief executive of
the integrated care system Ms J Milligan
and the regional medical director in
higher level responsible officer for the
south region of the NHS England Dr n
Atchison to ask a review of Thomas
Hospital closure plans I think we've
tried to be comprehensive in who we
write too chairman
councilman are you happy with that okay
so we don't need to have an amendment
councilor Philippine please microphone
thank you there's no doubt at all that
the retention of the hospital at
tinmouth will fulfill the community's
needs for
that type of facilities therefore I'm
very happy as the chair of uh I was
screw to the oversight and scrutiny
activity number two to say that this
will be accepted by that committee for a
detailed review albeit as we're moving
into a new election I'm sure that the
ons will take this up and run with it
I know that everybody
thinks the closure of the hospital is
the wrong thing to do and we are very
happy to get behind the recommendation
that it is reviewed in detail it has to
be retained it's vital for the community
and therefore we endorse the suggestion
the ideas contained in this motion thank
you
councilor Nutley here needs a Mike thank
thank you German
yes I'm the chair of the ashburton
Democracy uh League of friends and I
fully support this notice of motion I
know what we went through at the time in
trying to save our hospital I know we
lost the 10 inpatient beds but we have
no turn that into a fantastic Hub thanks
to Tracy Cunningham who is the sister
but as I say it was unfortunate we lost
the beds but as I say it's uh hopefully
we can save Tim at the hospital but I
fully support this totally thank you
councilor Nina Jeffers here
thank you
um
vitally important to retain services
like timmouth hospital I think anybody
that's uh had to use Healthcare over the
last few years will know how important
it is to a community to be able to
access something close to them people
shouldn't have to be traveling over 20
minutes to get to services that they
need for basic levels of Health Care and
especially when there are sites like
timoth hospital that are easy to access
and can offer services locally I think
where Community Hospitals are removed
there's greater strain
to deliver what's needed on the whole
community and we're already seeing that
with our services at the moment
shrinking healthcare services and our
populations where they're aging such as
in this area are a recipe for disaster
and Link that to other limited bus
services or poor roads
people having a lack of income and we've
got a system that's completely failed
its people we've seen in other towns
across the district and beyond that the
impact of closing Community Hospitals
have and I really hope that we can
retain the hospital in terms for its
people
thank you
are there any other speakers wishing to
speak on this um you you want to sum up
in a second
right I'd like to speak you don't need
to bring me a microphone I've got one
here
right thank you very much yeah I've been
right behind this campaign and it's
lovely to hear such what uh measures of
support from from councilors speaking
today uh I would like to comment on item
two when we uh we we which we've asked
to you which you've heard this is about
uh contacting uh Devon County council's
Health and adults uh social
care exclusionary Committee of which um
Sarah Randall Johnson is is the lead
counselor on that committee chair of it
we've had this before
and I don't know what went wrong the
minutes if you look at the minutes it
said it should have been examined on all
relevant matters yet it wasn't it was uh
it seems to me this is putting right a
correction
and hopefully that committee because
this time can be persuaded to do it
again and do what they should have done
in the first place examine it on all
relevant matters which they didn't do
we've made it specifically clear this
time that we wanted to see it examined
on the medical grounds the medical
evidence for keeping it home so
hopefully Devon County Council when it
gets there will put matters right and
correct what I see was a faux pas I was
always taught by the late Arthur blade
and look at the minutes
and what have you if you want
confirmation of things to be done and it
seems to me that Devon County Council
produced those minutes and then didn't
make sure that things were done and what
they said they they would do it on but I
I'm speaking rather passionately now so
I'm going to shut up and uh hopefully
we'll get a unanimous counselor Collett
now wants to speak on this to wind it up
thank you thank you chairman I feel
grateful to you and colleagues for all
of their comments and supporting uh the
motion to uh protect and save timoth
hospital it's often said chairman that
we don't know what we've lost until it's
gone and while I suspect no one will
more than the passing of covid when it's
finally defeated or some of the diseases
of years ago haven't been defeated by
Medical Science I think it's certainly
true that our estate in Devon of
Community Hospitals has been unloved and
left a decline over a number of years
and I can recall in the 1990s be NHS for
example investing in new hospitals
albeit in other places at Honiton
Orchard St Mary Tiverton okemton dawlish
for example
but here in teignmouth it's often said
that this is the first hospital in the
NHS and it provides a real service to
its local community but it's been
allowed to decline
but we know that in our main hospitals
there is an acute pressure on beds
because there is a shortage of people to
provide domiciliary Care at home and
this is creating a problem in our acute
hospitals and this is leading on to
delays in ambulances being able to
discharge into hospitals themselves
there is a virtuous circle that people
have received their acute care can then
go somewhere else into another NHS
facility before they perhaps go home or
into whatever long-term care may be
provided and yet that link seems to be
missing it seems to be unloved in fact
it seems to be something that the NHS is
turning its back on but the community is
right they know and love timoth hospital
as colleagues have said today the league
of friends is there Dynamic raising
money wanting wanting to give its money
to the NHS to support timoth Hospital
not another hospital in another place
but to support timmouth to support
timmouth people and the people who would
rely on timoth Hospital
if I have any regret whatsoever is that
this council is perhaps being late
to the campaign
I think in part because the NHS is not
ordinarily a matter for this Council it
is Devon County Council as you described
chairman
and there's others who have the power to
make the decisions to keep timoth
Hospital open
but I think it was entirely right of
colleagues to present the motion to
council and ask us at this 11th Hour
to do something which may only be a
series of letters to those people who
are in power and have the ability to
make the decision that's important to
timmouth but if we don't do it now then
I suspect the moment will be lost
chairman so in order to in order to
demonstrate to the NHS and to government
and to Devon County Council that this
this council is on this issue if nothing
else United I'm going to ask for a
recorded vote so that the CH the
managing director when he writes to the
NHS can say unanimously this cancer was
United in its support of timmouth and
Thomas Hospital and I invite those to
stand who wish to record a vote thank
you
foreign
you ready to do a vote trash
thank you
councilor Austin
councilor Bradford
Constable event councilor cold cloth
cancer connet councilor David Cox
councilor Hugh Cox
cancel the doors
cancer Dewhurst
councilor Evans
Council foden
cancer Goodman Bradbury
councilor Haynes
Council Hocking
cancer hook Jackie hook
councilor Jeffries
cancer Keeling
councilor McGregor or counselor Malone
councilor Nutley
councilor Parker
has appeared
no it's not here
counselor Phipps
since
Council Purser or councilor rollerson
cancer Swain
councilor Taylor
cancer Wiggly and your self chair oh
that's carried unanimously well
foreign
that's the strongest message that we can
possibly send when you get a unite
knighted vote from a council and thank
you members for for on behalf as
chairing out for making it unanimous
it's uh it's been a personal Battle of
mine as you know and I'm absolutely
thrilled about the result so I I think
we'll have a brief pause to let members
go because they may not wish to that
came about this particular item we have
a brief pause to let them out of the
room and Etc unless they particularly
want to stay on and hear about the
budget so we'll let them go I think
foreign
[Music]
well thank you members for allowing me
to get that one out of the way it was
lovely to see such you know unanimity uh
about this and so many people so happy
so thank you very much right let's move
to the budget uh now uh which is uh item
six isn't it it's having sort them
around
right
um executive member is councilor Keeling
for this he's going to get going so over
to you Richard
thank you thank you thank you Mr
chairman
colleagues I present the reports to you
today for your consideration in relation
to the final
financial plan proposals
2022-23 to 2025-26
the information is set out in appendices
1 through 216 in your papers
colleagues can I first pay tribute to
our staff who have contributed to the
savings and income generation made
especially our Chief Financial Officer
and his team for preparing this
financial this final financial plan
proposal for your consideration
colleagues as you're aware
we had the initial budget briefing in
January with all the relevant committees
giving councilors the chance to input
we have now consulted on the final
budget proposal with both overview and
scrutiny committees audit scrutiny and
executive committee this month
we have also consulted with town and
Parish councils in two meetings one in
December 2022 and one in January 2023 as
well as running this six-week public
consultation with teambridge residents
I have had many emails and conversations
with counselors on the details and I'm
pleased to say we are listening and we
acted where we can
on the public consultation
1036 people responded to the survey this
was three times the normal amount in
previous years
what was interesting was the survey
question on balancing the budget in the
future
78.33 agreed we should be generating
more income to reinvest in Council
services
34.71 agreed we should be making more
budget savings
8.43 agreed we should be reducing the
services we provide we will not be doing
that
23.4 percent agreed we should be
increasing council tax further and we
certainly won't be doing that colleagues
I would like to highlight the key parts
of our budget working with our Chief
Financial Officer and his team we have a
balanced fully costed budget using ear
March Reserves
we are proposing an increase in the
council tax to Five Pound fifty four on
bandi which is at 2.99 well below
inflation
colleagues we have spent a lot of time
on how can teambridge help our residents
with the cost of living crisis with
those who are struggling the most so
that we are
planning to give back to those
households the team bridge share of the
council tax increase
only a small part of the council tax
everyone pays comes to Cambridge Council
in fact this year it'll be closer to
eight percent of the whole amount
collected the rest goes to Devon County
Council the police and fire services and
local town and parishes
the proposed increase for teambridge
Council for a band D home is 554 for the
whole year that's about 11 Pence a week
we all know these are hard times with
prices rising inflation now still over
10 percent and so many people struggling
so we hope that by giving back this five
pound fifty four to every eligible
household whose main home is in
teambridge on the 1st of April 2023 in a
single payment we are doing our small
bit to help those many people who are
finding things particularly tough
this way we will be supporting residents
but still importantly helping to
maintain key Council Services into the
future
we have dealings with reduced central
government funding and the need to make
ongoing efficiencies using investor
Stave where possible
we have already pledged to maintain that
100 council tax support to be clear if
you're on a low income you will get 100
relief on your council tax
colleagues I reiterate in our budget we
are supporting our three key aims
climate emergency homes and jobs We are
continuing to react to the climate
change emergency by maintaining ongoing
budgets for our climate change officer
and Associated spending Temporary
Staffing Resources in revenue and
provision in the capital program
including ongoing provision for
corporate decarbonization schemes
our teambridge 100 housing scheme for
affordable housed social housing
continues with a provision of 8.5
million made over three years for phase
one
the team bridge 100 housing scheme is
benefiting those residents who are
desperate to stay in teambridge giving
families hope
teambridge 100 has delivered and
continues to deliver much needed modern
Council homes for local residents
of the 21 homes delivered to date we
have now new warm flats and family homes
in shouldley this coming week we are
handing over the keys to a newly
refurbished Bungalow to a local resident
who frees up
who has freed up a three-bedroom home
for a local family
and we have a new temporary
accommodation in the district much more
suitable rather than the bed and
breakfast when a family has an emergency
housing need
and we have another 24 homes coming
along in due course
we have also been working with local
housing associations to increase their
delivery of much-needed homes and we
look forward to delivering more new
Council homes around the district in our
towns and villages
colleagues we are also providing a 2
million provision for employment sites
funded by prudent borrowing supporting
jobs and business
a business case will be brought forward
from the economic development team to
members for consideration once it is
finalized
2023 colleagues will see over 20 acres
of employment land coming forward in
teambridge 16 acres is planned by the
commercial developers the remaining
smaller sites have been purchased by
indigenous businesses who are seeking
new bespoke buildings and the
opportunity to own the Freehold of their
workplace
the economic development team are
working closely with developers and
applicants in in an effort to find the
right location for both
colleagues we are continuing Our Town
Center investment in infrastructure and
employment
we are re-establishing Revenue
contribution to Capital initially at
three hundred thousand per annum and Our
intention is to increase to 500 000 in
the following years
charges at Newton Abbott indoor and
outdoor Market retailers continue to be
frozen after having been reduced
previously
and I am making a commitment for four
years to keep all car Parks free after 6
PM although this budget is for the
2023-24 supporting the nighttime economy
of our towns and we will freeze Sunday
parking charge at one pound for the
whole day
Leisure membership fees and
pre-application planning charges have
also been frozen
fees and charges will go up other than
those just mentioned at around five
percent less than half of inflation to
to due to Again cover increases in cost
due to inflation this will also help
towards increasing card payment charges
and rates increase arising from the
revaluation that mostly affects our car
parks
we have also set aside a provision for
emergency planning officer
colleagues the estimated Revenue budget
Gap was 3.6 million but now has been
reduced to 3.4 million in the
2025-26 and ongoing gaps before the use
of remaining earmark Reserves
we will take action required to address
this including establishing working
groups to inform overview and scrutiny
one and two on work to reduce the gap
to address the work required there will
be temporary funds for a scrutiny
officer to assist members with the
scrutiny function and the working groups
and I will work with providing
information to those working groups to
achieve our goals
we will also be supporting a digital
transformation manager and other
temporary resources to facilitate the
modern 25 work this work work was
started with the ignite undertook
colleagues we are continuing to support
enhanced planning funding
council's Community Fund for 2023-24
will be set at one thousand pounds each
reduced from 1 200.
and we will be given the opportunity
continuing the cost of living crisis We
are continuing to support our partners
in the volunteering sector CVS cab and
Newton Abbott community Transport Etc
we've also set aside a provision of
twenty thousand pounds for the year two
of the Tidy team bridge initiative which
will continue to improve the cleanliness
for our towns and Parish councils
and as agreed last year we paid off one
million pounds of the pension fund this
made a saving of 80 000 pounds we are
also proposing repaying a further 500
000 pounds in 2023-24 to reduce the
overall deficit driving down the past
deficit contributions and providing
returns which will be utilized to
support the cost of living payment in
2023-24
we are still an uncertain climate so we
will be increasing our general reserves
to 2.3 million from previously a 2
million
these proposals included draft revenue
and capital budgets for the three years
2023-24 to 25 26.
Mr chairman
I therefore propose that this Council
accepts the budget proposals as set out
from a to n
our Chief Financial Officer and head of
corporate services and I are available
for any questions that you may have
thank you Mr chairman
[Music]
uh so it goes to the floor for debate
Caster Phil bullovan if you can take the
mic
thank you for the explanation on the
budget
um
it is a valedictory budget in the sense
that this is the final year of this
Council
and therefore I think it's appropriate
to consider what we've achieved over the
last four years and see what this budget
says
there are claims in this budget which
I think are
interesting
I think if you look at the history there
are things that we're leaving to the
next Council
such as a 3.4 million black hole in the
accounts that are certainly not
addressed through any of the actions
within this budget
it's one heck of a legacy that we leave
for the next Council
we're handing out to every household
and the price of not always happy meal
the three hundred thousand pounds that
that's costing the council
only 42 percent of the people who voted
said that was the right thing to do they
wanted to invest in jobs and creating
the wealth and the income for the people
here as a preference
last year there was a two million pound
fund created to invest in these
activities that's repeated this year
last year none of that was spent
this Council has a poor record of
delivery if you look at the capital
program it's littered with projects that
have been there for a great number of
years but not brought to fruition
whether it be the Town Center
developments the investments in the
Leisure centers the investments in this
in the the towns that we have
if you look at the Investments that have
been made
the closure of timoth Lido last year
throughout the summer the hottest summer
on record
if you look at the failure to invest in
dawlish with the growth of people there
and the need for additional Leisure
facilities all of those funds were in
the budgets and have been in the budgets
for
a number of years but we have not
delivered against them
the critical thing however is how we
address the 3.4 million black hole
that's looming in the accounts
an out of Interest looking at the other
eight councils District councils in
in Devon and looking how they have
performed over that same period
timoth timbridge stands out we've used
more of our reserves over the last four
years than any other Council
in Devon
we have the biggest black hole in our
accounts we're the only Council for the
next year's budget that hasn't
identified where savings or income
generation could take place we rely
entirely on taking out of our budgets
the reserves that we have or spending
our Reserves
at a higher rate than any other Council
in Devon
this certainly is a valedictory budget
I know leaders of the controlling lib
Dem group are not standing in elections
I wish them well in their future careers
and lives but this
certainly is not a budget that I think
that would look back on with any
pleasure at all
we do we need better we have to accept
the challenges that the economy presents
and we have to move forward and make
sure that the children of this of this
District are not burdened with the sort
of debts that we're building up as we
move forward action should have been
taken needs to be taken and will be
taken by Future Council thank you
the next speaker is come
don't reply to that because that was
quite extensive
uh I'll yes okay we'll we'll take that
reply uh thank you Mr chairman you know
it's a bit Rich coming from the leader
of the conservatives
um his partying government where over
the past 12 years we've had reduced
funding from central government to the
extent that we are having to go out
there and and look at how we raise money
within uh teambridge and
he mentioned just one thing the light
over there the refurbishment money
that's been spent on the Lido yes we we
couldn't hope it in time
um in the last two weeks of the season
but what we actually did with the money
that we saved from that we gave that
over five thousand pounds to each of our
six swimming pools within our district
so I think he's been disingenuous with
what this Administration has done the
refurbishments of the Leisure centers
the decarbonisation of those as well as
Ford house
um we put forward a green plan
um to come out of
a conservative Administration that
wasn't delivering we are delivering
we're delivering on so many of those
aims and he talks about the two million
pounds I think he wasn't listening to me
when I was explaining how that two
million pounds for jobs and the economy
the reason why it wasn't spent last year
was there wasn't any need to this is a
re you know a
um
can I say a
money that we are actually
would borrow it's not money that we have
set there because of the reduced
government
um funding that we get we're having to
borrow that two million pounds to invest
but I've clearly set out in 2023 with
the 20 acres of employment land coming
forward and also a report coming to us
but can I also say I mean I I
we are dealing with this budget deficit
in
2025-26 by involving all councilors and
especially uh Council bolivants uh
overview and scrutiny too and providing
extra officer help to work together to
bring this deficit down and with the
ideas
um so I I would hope that he's going to
be involved with us in doing that rather
than you know him kicking it into the
long grass we'd make taking action now
thank you very much Mr chairman
right it's uh councilor Mike Hocking
next then David Cox
thank you chairman
um I find myself in a little awkward
position I'm actually agreeing on some
parts with cancer Boulevard
that's quite all right
but actually if we go back a few years
when uh the conservatives were in power
they used three years of government
grants in order to keep all council tax
down
to zero we're now paying for that
because part of the problem they had
then was that they could not foresee the
fact that there was a black hole
starting to appear
and we have that black hole now
even though
um Council Keelan said you're going to
look at it in 25 26. look black hole is
there now
I also find myself unable to support
this budget
because at the end of the day I feel
like as an elector not as a counselor
but as an elector I'm being calmed
calmed by this conservative they've come
by this lip Devon Administration and
elect an electioneering
I will still be paying
the increase of 5 pound 24 even though
they are giving it back to me as a
one-off payment funny enough just before
the election sometime in April
that would be very nice thank you
that'll give me an extra couple of pints
down at weatherspoons or go for a minute
or go for a meal at McDonald's
or joking aside
there is a hoe and sorry were they
getting this money from to pay us back
the five pound
2024 that um they're put in the council
tax up they're getting it back from a
saving they say they're making on paying
the um their part of the pension or
employees pension
all employers have a legal replication
to make sure they're they're paying
enough money into punching funds in
order to keep those funds afloat we've
already been told as a black hole in the
pension fund we know for a fact that
Devon county has a even bigger hole in
their part of the county they're part of
the pension fund
so at the end of the day we're gonna
we're gonna only give 500 000 into the
pension this year I'm going to keep the
other and I believe it's 300 or a
thousand to pay for this
um little handout just before the
election
I really do feel was all the people out
there aren't that silly the people who
will be electing this new Council and by
the way I shall be standing either
I've done 25 year I've done 20 years on
this Council in 25 years on tank Council
and I really do feel that this has been
the worst
four years of my political career within
them within tingbridge
basically because of the infighting and
the bait and the childness of some of
the people within this chamber
anyway oh that's my that's my thoughts
on the budget
I cannot support it and I will not be
supporting it because I feel it is an
election budget for an election year to
try and get people back and I think it's
all wrong that they should be playing
this with finances that we will need
when in coming years we've already been
told that they'll be in 25 26 we'll look
at it we need to be looking at it now we
need to be putting our house in order
now not then
foreign
would like to respond to that he thinks
that might be I'd just like to clarify
uh maybe councilor wasn't listening to
my report to the council
um that the additional 1 million uh
pounds last year and the 500 000 this
year is additional to what we're paying
into the pension pot and we've made a
saving because of that of 80 000 pounds
last year we intake to make a saving
this year so it's increasing that
provision to pay off the the pension pot
um so I I do believe that it you know
what the counselor said is is incorrect
and please listen to what I've said
but if I can come back briefly yes
briefly
it's good to be good healthy debate it's
a good healthy debate thank you uh
chairman for letting me come back yes I
do understand pensions I have been a
pension trustee so I do know how it
works you are you are committed to fill
the black hole that the pension fund has
okay you've put in a thousand a million
pound last year and 500 pound this year
and you say you've made a saving you're
only putting back in to what other other
administrations have not paid in not
taken not paid in over the over the
years so I do know how it works but it
is still you still are not filling that
black hole that it that exists in the
pension
but I'm hands are going up everywhere
but Alan when the leader would like to
respond to this and I think this is just
about this thank you I do employ
counselors not to confuse the pension
and certainly not to suggest the council
has not paid what it isn't due to pay in
previous years whatever administration
of any color or none there are many
reasons why there's a deficit on the
pension fund you can go all the way back
to Market Thatcher's government and the
requirement of councils to underfund you
can look at the fact that members of the
pension fund are living longer and
drawing pensions longer and the actual
aerial evaluations change you can look
at the way Investments work and the
returns are received by the pension fund
what the council has done and members
may recall when the council housing
stock was sold we made a one million
pound contribution to balancy uh pension
for those members of Staff who then
worked in the housing service we've
continued to make single one-off annual
payments on occasions last year and
proposed for next year
to help meet the deficit in doing that
it improves the or reduces the extra we
would have to pay as part of our Revenue
budget and that's where the saving comes
from and finally chairman just for
clarity
I'll come back to the politics of it
later but just for the clarity councilor
Hocking is Right obviously this council
is increasing council tax just to avoid
the very issue that he was talking about
because if we don't we lose it from the
base budget
and that generates the council tax
income which is being refunded and
topped up so it's money that is being
paid by our residence being paid back to
Residents because financially
the chief finance officer advises us
that's the best way to help residents
which is what the administration wants
to do and to ensure that the council has
the ongoing benefit of that money long
term and we don't lose it just in the
way that he described when we used to
get Council Tax Grants from the
government but it was actually lost from
the base thank you chairman
I I did know Richard at the back but I'm
coming now to Martin flickroff because
he can put a little bit of Officer
Clarity to this bit of the debate so
Martin
[Music]
yeah sorry just a touch on the the issue
around the pension fund so the way that
it works is that
um Devon County
revalue if you like the the liability
within the pension fund every three
years and within that they prescribe
what we've got to pay every year for the
next three years
um and it's a bit like paying off your
mortgage if you if you pay more quicker
then you'll then you'll get a better
return so we've got these prescribed
rates that we pay every year for three
years but on top of that in certain
years we paid an extra amount to reduce
that overall deficit we've got a
the plan with the County Council is to
reduce that deficit over the next 18
years and eliminate it and so these
payments that we make are projected
based on actual evaluations to do that
so I just thought the spec Clarity there
about what we are doing
um statutorily and voluntarily thank you
thank you Martin for that bit of a
Clarity there to the debate I've got
three more counselors and I'm not trying
to hurry anything along at all and
everybody should have the fa we've got
councilor David Cox Council Andrew McGee
and councilor Richard Dawes so it's over
to uh anybody else can put up their hand
catch my eye for the moment it's over to
councilor David Cox
it's worth noting that a third of all
Council across the country a third of
all Council Leisure facilities have been
closed because of the cost of living
crisis none will be closed in teambridge
so that's a pretty pretty good
achievement that we ought to uh applaud
uh accounts the Keating and certainty
councilor hook for their decarbonization
project not only we are we a Greener
Council but we're keeping stuff open for
people and it's and it's great to see
the grant scheme to help local
businesses get energy green energy
decarbonized energy so because we've
seen businesses in Tim of closing
because of energy costs so we're we are
looking to help our people and you know
people scoff at the um
the the five pound uh rebate that is a
meal for five you know uh when you when
you look at poverty actually you know
five pounds is is actually a lot of
money for some people
right it's to counselor Andrew McGregor
now over here
thank you chair
um
coming back to one of councilor
Boulevard's points I I particularly
around the overspending of reserves or
the highest uh Council for spending
reserves I do recall uh sitting in a
meeting and a presentation with uh the
officer Martin flickroft explaining that
they were taking a fairly large amount
out of reserves to pay off the pension
fund when we first started uh this
particular iteration of the of the
council
um and that would that would explain in
part why the reserves were in large part
used because it was a mechanism to save
money so you know I I lowered that
particular use in terms of a couple of
General points um I do have a concern
about we're taking an assumption of a
three percent pay rise for staff uh
bearing in mind that inflation is
running at 10.7 percent at the moment
and it does worry me that that'll make
it more difficult to recruit
in future
voluntary grants maintained at the same
levels I'm sure we all received that
heartfelt request for extra funds from
the citizens advice Bureau and I think
when we when we look at voluntary sector
and the support that they're putting in
particularly during this cost of living
crisis I think we should perhaps have
looked at
maybe some small increase at least for
funding for one or two of those
um in terms of the councilor Community
Fund no problem with that at all I think
a lot of my my fellow colleagues in the
chamber have probably not spent as much
but whatever's left in this particular
year perhaps we could consider
contributing all of that to the citizens
advice Bureau to support them
particularly in this time of increased
debt advice requirements evictions Etc
uh across the across the district
um I think the I think the uh increase
at 2.99 is excellent because it's well
below the cost of living
um or sorry the rate of inflation it's
actually below what we're able to to to
look at uh and I think it's an
interesting element that in my four
years as a counselor I've seen
the team bridge element of the council
tax in percentage terms reduced from
over nine percent to just over eight
percent so our proportion of the
collected council tax has reduced
steadily over that period of time and I
think that's actually quite positive for
this Authority
um I think from the the last point I
think we should continue to to try and
pay as much down on the pension to save
money in future and the more we deal
with now the easier that's going to be
particularly in a a high rate of
inflation period thank you chair
uh thank you Andrew it's now to
councilor Richard Dawes at the back
there
any other counselors this is catching my
eye thank you councilor Liam all right
uh thank you uh chair so I I note uh
councilor Boulevard's point of uh letter
with failures uh and not delivered uh I
suspect that uh given the business that
this Council doesn't revolve around
four-year Cycles it's continuous that
those failures uh spread to previous
administrations so he will show the
responsibility for that I also know his
point on on making savings uh whilst uh
uh the the previous uh vote and uh uh
big hurray of this council meeting was
to uh was to fund uh the local hospital
in teignmouth um I mean who wouldn't
want the hospital
um and who wouldn't want one locally and
I know the councilor Connor said we came
to this late
um surprisingly uh we're just about got
in time before the election
um I wonder if um any of the lib Dems or
conservatives could lend us any tub ads
because I I believe we've got to do the
uh statutory litter picks that's part of
our campaign but anyway the the council
is in an impossible position George
Osborne put it in that position when he
uh restructured the funding for local
councils to make all the motivation
based around house building which is the
delivery mechanism that this Council has
undertaken uh to uh to to sustain and
and we understand it's difficult uh and
we understand it's hard uh I I won't be
voting on this point uh because I've had
literally no time to look at the budget
there probably it's singly the most
important point of being a counselor
because this council is trashed my
reputation so spectacularly that this
week I've been talking to the MPS for
bath Vera hobhouse and the mp uh for
Brian Pavilion
um Caroline Lucas about the threat that
was uh created to businesses in their
Awards by the utterly Reckless actions
of this Council which caused my bank to
question if I was a fit and proper
person to be doing business with
um something that that happened in 2020
something I noted that has not been
addressed uh in in the apologies put
forward I know that uh councilor shears
uh councilor shares MD Phil shears
apology seven days uh uh apology that
should have been uh forthcoming from the
council's position last week has not
occurred uh I I suspect um the original
press release by the council that the
council was actually sorry that it got
caught by the Ombudsman rather than
sorry for what happened is actually the
case uh so I I won't be voting because
I've had zero time to look at singularly
the most important issue that this
Council has uh as as has to has to look
at because the council has trashed my
reputation thank you
next to him councilor Liam Malone
uh thank you um
I I do agree with some of um
Council of relevance points on the way
money has been spent
I find it very hard to believe that
whichever way you want to cook the books
um some of this whole wasn't created
with the
massive embarrassingly massive payoffs
of your to the agates and to bulbek uh
all of it engineered by our good friend
Jeremy Christophers
uh uh if if there's a if there's a hole
and I believe there is then I think the
conservatives and the liberal Democrats
have done equal Spade work on creating
it frankly
um in terms of this administration's
spending all I've seen is four years of
hiring expensive professionals who
weren't professional uh Consultants who
weren't real Consultants uh massive
wastage a decarbonization plan for Ford
house that cost three times what it
would cost to demolish and rebuild that
has now gone God knows where
a complete mess of the future High
Street fund let's face it you're not
going to see that money
and all along
misapplied plans miscaginated projects
just just an absolute mess but my
question my question today is two weeks
ago in the mid Devon Advertiser it it
there was a story in quite triumphal
terms that there would be no council tax
rise in tinbridge so I'm wondering who
on this Council gave them that story and
does the left hand actually know what
the right hand is doing right now
foreign
are there any other speakers before Alan
Alan sometimes
right Ellen it's your turn now
um thank you chairman uh well I'm sure I
brought the pic later than pick fault
all the time
um in terms of uh cancer Boulevard and
yes it is a valedictory budget for uh
some of us
um there's no black hole there is a
balance to be found for the budget
looking ahead
and work has been put in place to do
that over the past couple of years
working with the managing director and
chief officers that's what the ignite
work is about about modern 25 about
identifying a new way of working for the
council and in order to save money to
meet the impacts that we're all
experiencing
now councilor Boulevard says and it's
very true to say like other councils
they're in a different position in Devon
they're not doing what we're doing with
regard to the council tax never not but
if you look at those councils those
District councils in Devon what they're
doing is a mix of increasing costs some
of the more significance more
significantly for us than us
some of them are increasingly okay all
of them all of the others are increasing
their council tax
uh but they're not doing what we're
doing they're increasing costs or the
charges of increasing their council tax
and the cutting services to a greater or
lesser extent all of them
it is at this Council and this Council
alone which is taking the battle on the
cost of living crisis to the residents
by saying yes we need to protect the
council's income by increasing the
council tax but we're giving the
equivalent of the band D five pounds 54
back per year and on top of that we are
broadly keeping on any increases in our
charges to an average of five percent
there is no more as a small District
Council that we can do but what we are
doing is what everyone needs and some
people may scoff in say 554 it's no more
than a Happy Meal it's no more than a
couple of pints in wetherspoons
but that's councilor Cox said
for very many households that five
pounds 54 will go some way to help
it won't go far I appreciate that but it
will go some way to help and it may be
an extra charge on the electricity meter
or whatever it might be but we are
standing with the people of teambridge
and for those who haven't had the time
to read the budget which I understand
I'd commend it to you because there are
investment programs in here which
support teambridge there's a revenue
budget which supports teambridge
but I just want to talk about something
else if I may last week I was at Devon
County Council
um and it was their budget meeting
their budget was approved the council
relevant supporting it
with a requirement for 12 million from
reserves to support the budget
4 million from the public health Reserve
to support the budget and a requirement
to save 47 million pounds
and of course in the intervening couple
of years and against all the warnings
the County Council has built up a debt
of about 100 million pounds on special
educational needs because in part
they have not been able to manage that
demand and the government underfunds
Devon County Council just in the way
that it underfunds this Council there is
a financial crisis facing all councils
in Devon which is about the government's
decisions on funding to local
authorities and I have to say the
economic crash engineered by Liz truss
in three days
in this country for us
this budget has gone through overviewing
scrutiny anyone's been able to ask any
question about it
and this brings me to a point that I
want to just emphasize before I conclude
this budget is not possible without the
hard work of all of the council's staff
and officers and I want to put on my
record on record my thanks to them for
all their hard work and diligence and
advice they provided
I'm grateful to all of the chief
officers and the senior leadership team
for what they've done but also and it's
easy to forget isn't it in this four
year period
that for all of us we have been blighted
in what can be achieved by two years of
covid lockdown
precautions around that I am
tremendously proud of the way this
Council responded to covid went out and
helped people went out and contacted the
most vulnerable has been able to
maintain the budget for cab CVS for
Newton Abbott community Transport and
others when other councils have been
cutting back we have been steadfast in
our support for the community and this
budget is the headline act for a great
show which says we understand what our
residents and voters and communities
feel oh well people may scoff because
it's only five pounds people may laugh
in the back seats because they may have
more money than they know what to do
with but we know poverty faces
teambridge and this council is doing the
right thing and I commend this budget to
every member and anyone that abstains in
my view is abdicating their
responsibilities thank you chairman
foreign
vote so no members need to to stand so I
think it's time to
as it's been said it's now put to the
vote are you ready to do the vote trash
yes thank you chair right so
councilor Austin
Council Bradford
cancer Boulevard
because the cold cloth Council connet
Council David Cox councilor Hugh Cox
cuts the doors
cancer Dewhurst
councilor Evans
councilor foden
okay so Linda Goodman Bradbury
councilor Haynes
councilor Hocking okay
okay that's the Gordon hook
it's a jacking hook
okay so Jeffries
councilor Keeling or councilor McGregor
councilor Malone
councilor Nutley
councilor Parker
councilor Purser
rollerson or councilor Swain
councilor Taylor
councilor Wigley and yourself chair
that's character
I believe two other members missed the
opening address by the portfolio holder
so I don't think their votes should be
noted thank you
I'll I'll just take advice on that
we're being told it was councilor David
Cox and I think Dave councilor David Cox
did you come back in and counselor Evans
left so that's what I noted
sorry I didn't know I didn't think
just take a bit of advice here
at the end of the day apparently we
can't stop you voting is that correct
I'm sorry that's corrected it can't stop
them if members weren't passed during
the whole debate then any decision that
they make is chargeable it's clawed I
mean it's a matter for Council yeah it's
a matter of the counselors you've voted
apparently so you know
the record shows what you've done so I'm
sorry that you missed the first part of
the debate and what have you but I I
think it's it's a relatively
small decision uh you you
in the fact that it's only it's only two
of you isn't it and you've just missed
the the very opening things but you've
made your decision you voted it's up to
you if anybody wants to challenge it
they have the right to do that councilor
Rayne Evans
okay you know
Council
so you did hear it through the walls you
know yeah councilor Boulevard
thank you I understand the decision
taken
exceeds the number of if those three
votes were to be discounted it didn't
make any difference whatsoever so well
that was my feeling so there we are so
yeah I think we put that one to Ben
thank you
let's move on to the next item it was a
good debate and everybody got hurt and
I'm glad we let the hospital people
um they didn't need to sit through all
that so I feel my watering the order my
decision was Vindicated thank you it was
very healthy lengthy debate and perhaps
not all of them would have wanted to sit
through that and then move on to the
hospital issue so thank you
right now let's move on to the next one
it's the leader to introduce internet
uh the community governance review for
ogwell Parish thank you thank you
chairman I believe councilor colclough
would like to move it and I'm quite
happy to defer to councilor conclave if
she wishes
so certainly counselor colclough please
Mike
I suppose that we go along with ogwell
having two more counselors for their
Parish Council
um the boundary has been extended at
dogwell but on top of that they've had
considerable amount of development there
with aqua Brook and and other large
developments so I think this is well
deserved by the parish council so I'd
like to propose that we go along with
having two more counselors secondary
chairman
[Music]
right it's been seconded thank you
uh thank you councilor Mary colecroft
for doing that you've been a stalwart
member of that Council for years and
years and it's lovely to see you
proposing it thank you
uh right who actually wanted to speak
did you want to speak on this Andrew did
you you didn't okay is there anybody
else to speak on it while we go to the
vote
I think we can do this by show of hands
can't we yep so all those in favor of
that
anybody what is it unanimous I'm going
to say I anybody against was there any
abstentions so it was unanimous thank
you
to the next item which is the uh item
nine the recommendation from the strata
joint executive committee of the 17th of
January uh 2023 and this is the Deputy
leader to Alistair councilor Alistair
Dewhurst to introduce thank you
that thank you chair
um so on the 17th of January uh the new
IT director of strata Mark Davis
introduced their uh strata
um plan uh business plan for 23.24 and
that was approved by the strata joint
executive meeting
um and so the recommendation before you
today is that we in this Council approve
that that business plan so that work can
get on and we can get our modern 25
program through and can be supported by
strata thank you Joe
where's the second and for that
Martin councilor Martin Wrigley because
he attends to you attend those meetings
don't you
right on the humorous now I was chairman
of that for a year in the rotation of
the of the overview and scrutiny
Committee of strata and we never met
once in that year in my chairmanship so
there we go this is the stronger
executive I understand I understand that
but as chairman of the overview of
scrutiny business for a whole year we
never met once so I missed my my my turn
at the chair as it were
let's go to the vote on that please and
unless anybody wants to speak on it does
anybody want to speak on it
no right we go to a vote and that can be
done by a show of hands those in favor
of it please
those against
and those abstaining
that's character carried
you I'm very bad at that my apologies uh
it's on to item 10 now the notices of
motion
and uh
notice of motion for it so let's look at
that one
countless the Nutley that presented this
this motion so is it um
two-thirds of the council we have to
vote if you want to debate that today
he wants to introduce it first it's
probably a good idea wouldn't it right
and Away you go
thank you chairman um I know I'm a
Dartmouth National Park member as well
but um obviously we've had all these
issues with the uh Banning of some areas
of the Dartmoor for wild camping and
backpacking as their class and he does
know
um I trust everyone's read my notice of
motion unless you want me to read
through it I would ask you to support
that notice of motion and that the this
Council obviously rights to Devin uh to
Dartmouth Park in support of their pill
against the Banning of the wild camping
thank you
seconded there secondly there thank you
so is it the wish that uh this be
debated today would you want to speak
just speak on that I I think it'd be
very helpful if it's debated today and
Council makes the decision to enable a
letter that got the earliest opportunity
to uh DMP well we need two-thirds of the
council to vote on that so by show of
hands uh if you wish to heard it debated
today could you raise your hands
that's clearly Karen so have it debated
now in front of us so uh who's uh who's
gonna uh are you gonna speak more on it
now
do you want to speak more
so Connor chairman I I support the
motion I think very many people were
hugely disappointed when uh the courts
decided to effectively ban while camping
on Dartmoor I think DMP Dr National Park
are doing great work and trying to
recover that and we've got an interim
position on it
um I'd be surprised if anyone in the
council is anything other than support
of while camping and re retaining or
regaining that right for people to go to
Wild camp on Dartmoor um I think the
motion had probably been put
yeah
Council believe it
thank you I agree that it's an excellent
idea to support this motion the one
concern I have nowhere in this motion
does it does it reflect responsible
World camping and if we have wild Raves
people lighting fires barbecues and
things like that we just have to be
careful what we wish for and I think we
should have something in here which we
respect or highlights the need for
responsible wild camping as opposed to
just wild camping thank you
foreign
thank you chair so um I I will remember
in my childhood
um in in a very leaky tent
um the many many weekends that we we
spent on Dartmoor camping as a family
um it it gave my family a great love of
camping and in fact led to my parents
um long time business
in in terms of camping
um so obviously I will be supporting
this
um I'm not sure that it really needs any
kind of uh addition to to the uh to the
motion
um because I think by definition wild
camping is a responsible type of thing
um it's better to to walk and just leave
your footprint when you go and I think
that's what most people on Dartmoor do
and would like to continue to do and I'm
glad that this I hope this Council will
be supporting that thank you
and so with the councilor Cox then
councilor Swain I agree with the the
previous Council we don't we don't we
don't need to change anything there
already exists by laws and uh Rules by
Dartmoor National Park that prevents
basically Raves Etc uh so it's it's
quite clear
um the the landowner at the center of
this purchased the the estate knowing
that their uh that wild camping was
allowed and then sought the courts to
take away that right so I think we
should we should give this absolutely
our support and I thank councilor
Natalie for bringing the motion
all right she comes to the swing next
please thank you thank you privilege to
support this motion
um I've been wild camping with my
children since they were tiny as adults
they now go World camping with others on
Dartmoor this right was one of the
reasons we considered when we moved to
the area
um I did want to respond to the point
about responsible use
um I think this is a right which is
being attacked and Urgent he needs to be
defended I think it'd be entirely
inappropriate to say we want this right
back but obviously you need to put some
things in to make sure that it's
responsible that's not appropriate in
the context of this motion we just need
to write in support of the right to Camp
thank you
councilor Richard doors at the back
hi thank you
I'll I'll not give a big long example of
my family using uh Dartmoor I think
everyone does it's uh clearly uh a
motion that we should support
um the uh
the the addition of of some sort of
hysterical Daily Mail headline of wild
meaning wild in a different context this
is not required uh totally ludicracy was
absolutely sham that the high court uh
passed the uh the the appeal that was
put forward by the landowner uh the the
case that was put forward by uh the
Barrister Timothy leader will hopefully
be appealed uh and it's worth noting
that Timothy leader is is a barrister
that I I've worked with in fact he was
the Barrister that advised me that this
Council had broken the law uh the Local
Government Act and uh um and bridged my
human rights and that was put to the
council in December 2020 and they chose
to ignore it uh so I assume he'll
Prevail in time as well and that the
wild camping decision will be reversed
as well so I couldn't support this
motion uh any stronger thank you
is councilman McGregor over here please
thank you chair
um
you know with with my my Scottish
Heritage I do find this a little bit of
a strange situation anyway the the right
to roam is is inherent in Scottish law
which is a really interesting comparison
with with uh English law
um I'm fully in support of this and and
I'm not surprised that the this Council
and this authorities is fully in support
of it considering 40 of our district is
within the national park boundary
um it's really important for our
residents it's really important for
visitors to the area it's really really
important for our local economy and our
businesses that we don't discourage
people from coming down those that come
down while camping I've seen no evidence
to show that they are taking advantage
being unpleasant uh being anti-social
most people that come down to Dartmoor
are
very well-behaved people and they do
respect Dartmoor and I think that you
know from my perspective I'm fully
behind this um motion and I think it's a
really important one for Dartmoor
National Park to understand that they
are supported by all of the districts
around there around their National Park
boundary thank you
are there any other speakers
suffice to say I'd like to have a quick
oh
thank you Joe just just a quick one on
this um I appreciate everyone's support
on this I'm actually at Dartmouth park
for a meeting on on Friday and I will
pass on the good news to uh our
councilor sorry Kevin Bishop thank you
both under this ocean too myself I led a
team around when I was 18 and on 10
tours 50 miles in those days and uh it's
great to be out on Dartmoor doing these
sort of things and so I'm behind it as
well so just for the record just wanted
to make that thing so if you can go to
the vote please I think we can do
we can do this by a show of hands uh all
those in favor of the motion please
raise their hands
it was unanimous as you quite rightly
said right
so we go on to the next motion
uh
and that's been presented by councilor
Malone isn't it uh who's it presented by
councilor patch and supported by with
councilor patches and here to support it
I think Council doors you'll do it will
you yeah yes yes uh I thought counselor
patch had noted that the motion would be
uh spoke to by myself
um that's fine okay so uh so I'll I'll
just do a brief one-page sort of
statement and then the council can
decide whether he wants to debate or
vote on the motion
um so the Ombudsman found serious faults
uh with the administration in terms of
Standards cases at this Council uh
concluding then Justice Done to myself
uh constituted wider systemic problems
uh they made the the report public due
to the public interest so so not just
for this Council to learn from but for
other councils so it would be remiss if
we didn't learn from it ourselves last
week's extraordinary meeting was called
to consider and address the ombudsman's
findings but he failed to do so in
particular avoided to address the
systemic problems the injustices uh that
I have uh suffered have been married by
other serious case serious failings in
other cases and I've shown a light on
the standards procedure that is not fit
for purpose team bridge standards
procedure has been abused by senior
councilors and officers over a sustained
period the common link between
councilors subject to the abuse of power
as that they've carried out their roles
in uh in debasing and and and
challenging uh and picking fault not
litter uh the council's actions
other other abuses of procedures include
those made on large-scale planning
decisions cases needing consideration
were outlined in my reports of old
Council delivered at the egm on the 14th
of February uh and then bullet point
form they contain the flawed standards
proceeding against myself the same
flawed standards proceedings against
councilor Malone floor standards
proceedings against councilor patch
failures to investigate planning
procedures when grunting of Lanford
Bridge January 2020 the planning
advisory service ignored five of the
concerns we raised you don't know what
you've lost Till It's Gone TDC breached
the local government acting not allowing
public into a climate change briefing on
the 24th of September the lgo have noted
to me in a communication having seen the
uh the email string that no sensible and
reasonable reason was given for not
complying with that complaining to
cancer Boulevard conflict of interest
was whitewashed and hidden the criminal
harassment by councilor believant son
against councilors was not dealt with
questions raised about Langford bridge
in September 2021 remained unanswered
and the assault on councilman loan was
ignored standards procedures against
councilor Eden Russell and Cox need to
be reviewed stanza standards procedures
and legal advice to the council in 2018
needs reviewing suggestions have been
made that a solicitor who was struck off
in 2010 was engaged and advised the
council and finally the council needs to
demonstrate it has instructed work on
na3 with all full planning permission in
place it really would be quite something
if after a decade of debate planning
appeals legal challenges if this Council
had commence work without planning
permission in place the individual cases
of Mal Administration outlined by the
Ombudsman in my case a cause for concern
on their own but when combined with the
multiple failings in multiple standards
cases that demonstrate large-scale abuse
of power that have reached the threshold
possibly of misconduct in public office
or Miss Visions in public office those
are criminal offenses that carry
custodial sentences it's for those
reasons I propose this motion and that
the council appoints Commissioners to
administer and guide the council until
the elections of May
2023 I propose the motion thank you
foreign
so can you note the hands please
so it's debated today
right
who wants to open the debate
Council Connor chairman uh thank you
very much for that
um
I listen
I listen to what councilor door says
and I can't help but feel
that he interprets things as he wishes
them to be rather than as they are
on January 19th I provided a full and
unreserved apology
and I did so again last week at the
extraordinary meeting
they report to that extraordinary
meeting have three recommendations and
we brought forward 10 which Council
supported and dealt with the issue is
now I can quite understand
that some people think that because the
council agreed to write to the Secretary
of State and the local government
Association for some clarity
that they choose to interpret that is
somehow it's sorry but not sorry and I
dealt with that at the time it's only so
that's not the case
I have given an unreserved apology the
council accepts the ombudsman's report
however there do appear to be some wider
matters
of interest to all the local government
family
which are worthy of being explored that
does not detract from the ombudsman's
report
that appears to be Lost in Translation
never repeated
the ombudsman's report was very specific
and that it reply applied to councilor
Dawes
and it made observations and
recommendations with regard to the
complaint that councilor doors made to
the ombudsman
didn't deal with other matters other
people so far as I know
from what they have said not that I know
in any other way have either gone to law
or gone to the Ombudsman and the
Ombudsman for whatever reason has
declined to take up their their case or
their complaint or the Law Courts have
determined a different outcome
um last week's meeting I think councilor
patch explained what his circumstances
were and he said that he'd gone to the
European court and they had said that
they had no jurisdiction but those were
matters that councilor Council patch
correction cancer patch
conform to counselor I have no knowledge
of those things other than what was said
but I do think it's important that we
don't allow
four years of good work to be overrun by
World chairman it's interesting is that
Council doors is heard in silence people
are paying attention and then people
coming in and then laughing when other
people are speaking and this is part of
the issue that faces this Council
the issue that faces this council is
that if we were going to invite in the
inspectors or the Commissioners we
should do it to look at the behavior of
some counselors the shouting the
swearing the constant interruptions the
inability to let other people speak
even if you don't like what it is they
are saying and have their free speech I
believe I believe last week we heard
that all as counselors we have an
enhanced right to freedom of speech
albeit that it has to be moderated with
our responsibilities as well
so perhaps I can have freedom of speech
uninterrupted today
I think the issues as well is that the
council also need to consider
um the many things that we have done
that serve the community
so we didn't discuss it during the
budget debate but it is worth the of
note that there have been a near
threefold increase in the number of
people taking part in this year's budget
consultation
1036 up from 355 last year now I'm not
excited about 1036 it should be more but
it shows that more people took part and
actually the council undertakes an
annual satisfaction survey and that also
shows that there is an improvement in
the number of people who are very or
fairly satisfied with the way the
council is run actually a small increase
up from just under 47 to just over 48
percent
additionally 81 of respondents are very
or fairly satisfied with the local area
as a place to live and that's up from 77
percent
so the indicators in terms of real
people living in teambridge and paying
their council tax and looking to their
Council for services is on the change
it's moving in the right direction
none of that detracts
I entirely accept none of that detracts
whatsoever
from what council of doors experience
and what they describe to us as a
council and I have apologized once twice
three times
but councilor doors doesn't accept my
apology because he choosed as a spin on
him
and I want to come to another point
I had an email sent to me from a lady
called Jane Taylor
actually yesterday on the phone I had a
phone call from a news organization who
said they have been sent a copy of that
letter
what did I have to say about it chairman
I said I don't know no one said the
courtesy to send it to me but half an
hour later it did come through from Jane
Taylor
and there are some things in there that
again are that particular spin which is
part of the South Devon Alliance
election campaign for May and other
things I'm sure
but the essence of it all is isn't it
that while I wholly accept
the wrong process is used
in relation to the standards matters
that pertained to councilor doors
I do not accept that this council is a
bad organization I do not accept that is
a failing organization I do not accept
that government time funds and money
need to be spent on Commissioners here
but if some were Commissioners it should
be on the behavior of a small handful of
counselors who have time and time and
time again
be rated shouted sworn lost their temper
and try to prevent other people speaking
and have it behaved in a way which I
would describe as intimidatory bullying
harassing
and they have failed themselves to
condemn it or to hold it back
so I'm voting against the motion today
because I believe the council has
apologized and gone way beyond that
which was in the original
recommendations to council last week
whereas a lesson to be learned
and as members will know
we've also asked that proper processes
put in place so there's training in the
new Council period very early on jointly
for senior leadership team Senior
Management and the new council is
joining the council we can't put right
to pass but we can make the better for
the future better chairman so I oppose
the motion
and I should be voting against it thank
you chairman
councilor Liam Malone and councilor Andy
Swain after that I expect one or two
more Mike wants to speak to catch my eye
if you do Council McGregor okay
thank you chair
um I'll be very short and to the point
so that nothing can be
misinterpreted or spun or any of the
stuff that councilman says is going on
um
just please look at the facts
you broke the law
yeah you broke the law you broke your
own Constitution and not only did you
break your own Constitution you tried to
rewrite it so that it agreed in
retrospect with what you've done
you employ Karen trigger who did that
and then Mr Woodhead who did that
you also broke the European sorry not
the European the UK Human Rights Act
the liberal Democrat executive in
conjunction
with the officers broke the UK Human
Rights Act this isn't some frippery that
you can ring fence and sweep away and
said oh well we've done this and we've
done that
it's a catastrophe okay and that's only
that's not the iceberg that's the tip of
it there is a lot more to come
there is lies there is law breaking
there is fraud you'll hear about it very
very soon I would take the exit while
it's open
if I was you and if I can just say a
quick word on all this stuff about how
you try and justify breaking the law
because we're a bit Rowdy and a bit
sweary and a bit annoying yes we are uh
I don't know if you can remember when we
first joined this Council we were good
as gold for the first three months we
put our hands up to go to the toilet for
the first three months we and then we
realized we were getting treated like
dog and we represent people who are
getting treated like dog and that
is why we are a bit rude and we'll
continue to be a bit rude until we are
sitting on a castle that isn't Criminal
thank you
foreign
who says the criminal offenses the
police would be very willing to and we
will cooperate if you wish to report to
the police this council is open it's
transparent despite your thoughts it
didn't no I
okay so now we can't report all right I
I I can't answer that I don't know I'm
not amazing I wouldn't know who is and
who isn't
um in terms of unlawful this Council
didn't act unlawfully the only person
who could make that decision is a court
the Ombudsman can't make that decision I
have a letter in front of me from the
Ombudsman saying that he cannot decide
he cannot give a judgment
okay
so that's pointless that's a
non-startering you know it is just
claimed that we are acting criminally
yeah so a criminal offense is a police
thing if you have a complaint to yet
again councilor alone
right the next speak
it would be
we have always tried to investigate
whether you appreciate the process or
not whether you like it the process is
there please use the process if you
think criminal offenses have been
um have taken place reported to the
police if you think that we are doing
something we need to be done we will try
and process it or we will process it
through the channels that you have
provide the evidence and we can see it
you've made lots of complaints and you
provide very little evidence so much of
it is your perception to my mind because
I I don't see evidence in front of me
that we can look at much of it is
perception and Views as opposed to
evidence in reality from my position
right I want to have the next case it
was three more counselors to hear from
councilor Swain Counter McGregor and
councilor bullerman so we go with
councilor Swain first please and
councilor hook you won't speak with
foreign
there is an election coming up we all
know that we're all up for election can
we please not uh claim that everything
we do is is marvelous and wonderful and
everything everybody else does is just
spinning electioneering can we please
treat each other equally and with
respect thank you I have read carefully
the ombudsman's report
um paragraph 19 does Clearly say that
the Ombudsman does not comment on
whether or not anybody's human rights
have been breached it is very important
that we read what the report actually
says I also note that Mal Administration
is a word which was used by councilor
doors in his introduction but that word
does not appear in the ombudsman's
report nor does malfeasance which is a
word which was used earlier these all
reply all refer to deliberate wrongdoing
the word that does appear in the report
is misfeasance which refers to
Accidental wrongdoing
discounts has already agreed to accept
the report and implement the
recommendations in full this motion
invites the council to invite government
to come in and take over our operation
this is not a measure that was
recommended by the Ombudsman we should
implement the recommendations as they
have been set out not make up our own so
I will be voting against this motion
thank you
councilor Boulevard over here next and
it's cast The Hook and we'll councilman
McGregor I'll put you there thank you
like most councils here go back four
years
almost the first thing that we heard
were declarations from our colleagues
that they didn't believe the council
worthy of support they expressed their
opinions in terms of this Council
had no legitimacy because it had the
temerity to approve a planning consent
in na3
subsequently
there's been a Litany of allegations
made against myself my family other
counselors
which everyone
has been investigated
everyone has been referred for external
examination I can only speak for myself
and my family in this matter
everyone that I've received which had
been several have been referred for
independent check validation in every
case
the
opportunity to present evidence has been
offered and refused to be complied with
by the people who made those allegations
because there is no validation
in the claims that they've made no truth
in the allegations that they've made
if one goes back three years we had a
scenario in this Council where a
counselor used his
identity badge to admit into the secure
area of the offices
protesters who went forward to contest
and confront officers
in an aggressive unprovoked
manner which generated a huge amount of
stress to the officers and employers of
this Council
in seeking to address that
and bring the counselor to book to the
extent which is allowed by the process
which enables or requires a counselor
who's shown to be in breach of rules to
apologize
nothing else apologize and that is the
process that the council sought to go
through
yes because it'll be never envisioned
in the processes and procedures of this
Council that a counselor would behave in
such a such a manner
the process is that the council use was
subsequently found
not to comply
with an interpretation of our rules
and three years ago that was recognized
by the monitoring officer the new
monitoring officer and a process put in
place to review all of our processes and
procedures to come forward with ideas
suggestions and recommendations that
would apply to this Council that is an
ongoing process
yes there are things we want to change
yes the things we want to improve and
yes we need to recognize that councilors
have a duty to behave in a particular
way with respect and it respects the
Nolan principles
being truthful telling the truth
behaving with respect and listening to
others are all part of those things
hitherto I'm afraid we haven't been a
Council that's been able to do that
for that reason I cannot support this
motion and I ask other counselors to
reject it as well thank you
look over here please
thank you chair
um in my almost 12 years as a district
councilor
I don't believe that when I've spoken at
a council committee meeting that I've
ever interrupted or spoken over someone
else when they are speaking
even when that person may have been
engaged in personally abusing me
I merely ask that I'm afforded the same
courtesy
although I have no intention of
personally abusing anyone
I'd like to speak against the notice of
motion
as has already been said there seems to
be a desire amongst some to rewrite a
different version of what this
Administration and Council agreed in its
recommendations at the extraordinary
council meeting last week
so let's make it clear again councilor
Connor has apologized unreservedly for
the process errors that were made in the
consideration of councilor door's
standards case
we also fully agree with the ombudsman's
recommendations for action and put in
place a framework for those actions to
be taken forward
it was a proper apology and not
half-hearted in any way so let's clear
that up for starters
I'd like to go on to add something else
I hear that some have called on some
well called on councilors
um as a collective
indeed Jane Taylor did it in her letter
that we have been weak for not standing
up to bullying and intimidation and for
not speaking up
and you know what they are right a lot
of us have been afraid to speak up for a
long time
years in fact
and I'd like to speak up now
put simply
I and I believe others have felt
intimidated and bullied by NSN
counselors
and I treat them as a collective because
neither has called out the other
and it is them that we have been too
afraid to stand up to
so some context
back in 2019 NSM were coming into
existence and into the public
Consciousness mostly via a website
that website had a Rogues gallery
which named Council officers and
existing councilors some of them here
and one of the council officers Phil
shears
now some will know that I am a supporter
of Fairly robust and unconventional
campaign techniques some of the issues
we are tackling in our world today were
petitions and nice letters haven't
worked need something more robust in
terms of campaigning
something to make those people in power
wake up to take notice and something
that frankly may upset some people
and climate change is one of those
issues
now I fully accept that NSN wished to
robustly put forward their views on at
the beginning essentially a single issue
of na3
many of their views were views held also
by us as lib Dems
I can see that they wanted to use
unconventional methods to get noticed in
a way that perhaps Wilbur residents
Association hadn't managed to achieve
but nowhere in the list of
unconventional robust and effective
campaign techniques will you find the
personal abuse of people their
unconnected family members and those
that you wish to engage with if and when
you were elected
this is what their website did
and it seems that many people don't
remember or aren't aware of this website
which was available to view long after
the election of May 2019.
so in nsn's Rogues Gallery there was a
photo of Phil shears next to it there
was a photo of Phil Shear's daughter
with the words
here's a joke for you what's the
difference between Phil shears and a
reality TV star
one is a Shameless tart who'll do
anything for money the other is that
word sorry I haven't got recorded Well
we'd laugh if it wasn't so tragic
there are then two other paragraphs of
General
well you can finish it later there are
then another two paragraphs of General
personal abuse of Phil shares
other Council officers and councilors
suffered the same abuse on their website
I'm sure we can all agree hopefully that
this is bullying and intimidation in its
basist form deeply hurtful to those on
the receiving end
these methods are not effective campaign
tools
is it any wonder that relationships
between officers NSN councilors and
other councilors were strained from the
outset
did the NSN councilors seek to apologize
or move away from this well they did
post this on their website when they
finally took down its functionality
so this is a quote as an act of good
faith in the new executive and the
various other people will need to
Wrangle with we've suspended
functionality on this website for the
time being
we are not however putting our satirical
weapons Beyond use
our objective Remains the Same the local
plan must be revised and by revised we
mean hung drawn quartered torn apart by
horses it's head put on a spike outside
Asda and the remains thrown into a
plague pit with the careers of the
people who devised it
if that doesn't happen then this site
will be back up with some updates
so no they've not apologized but have
rather continued their personal abuse
and intimidation via social media and
Council committee meetings
so that most counselors are afraid to
speak out against them in case they have
the same personal abuse hurled at them
and maybe their family members by NSN
counselors and their supporters
but what went seriously wrong from there
I would suggest and I don't know that
have knowledge of this is that without
that hurt repaired amongst officers and
with ongoing incidents senior officers
at the time lost track of due process in
their desire to see these counselors
brought to task
that is wrong whatever it is that
Council adores is accused of he deserves
to be investigated and judged by Fair
process and he wasn't
that is why we issued a full unreserved
apology for this failure of process last
week and took on board all of the
ombudsman's recommendations
but I do feel now that today would also
be a good place for NSN counselors to
apologize for the unnecessary hurt
and I say unnecessary because they had
no effective campaign purpose and was
merely gratuitous and deeply hurtful
so the unnecessary hurt and upset they
have caused officers and other
counselors of this Council
I would finally add that I have in my 12
years as a counselor always acted only
in the best interests of my residence
and to be continually accused of doing
otherwise I have had to learn to put up
with but I shouldn't have had to learn
to put up with that
there has been no evidence forthcoming
of any of the planning wrongdoings that
have been alleged against this Council
and councilors with regards to an E3 in
Langford Bridge
as has been said councilman Malone has
made many accusations but few have been
evidenced
and I'm glad I finally was brave enough
to speak up thank you
it's over to councilman McGregor now put
the Border I think I ought to be allowed
to respond to that
I'll I'll come back to you in a second
I'm taking the order you want to speak
next
thank you Josh
um
I'd just like to thank councilor hook
for her uh quite passionate speech
um it's it is an interesting uh Odyssey
over the last four years but I would
like to draw a little bit further back
to a previous comment by councilor con
it
and I thought you'd remind him that uh
pots calling the kettle black is not a
good look for anybody he's walking away
from this council at the end of April
um he's asking for everybody to be
investigated
um councilors behaviors but I would like
to draw him back to a meeting in this
Council
in this particular place where in
response to a motion
councilor con it launched into a
personal attack on five other councilors
a note that personal attack involved
drawing false Illusions to uh to
register of interests
so I think it's a very very dangerous
thing for a counselor to call other
counselors out on their behavior when in
effect his own behavior and some of his
colleagues as well has been lacking
so I think it's it's really important
that we should consider this Motion in
terms of what it's actually requesting
what is the purpose of the motion and
what is the outcome if it is voted
through that's all we're here to do
we're not here to make personal attacks
on people which is
um another not not good look is to to
criticize members of the public or in
the in the gallery
um so from my perspective I think it's
really important and I've had a I've
I've had somebody uh question why I I
backed this motion I think it's really
important that we have democratic debate
at all times even on matters we don't
necessarily think are particularly nice
matters to discuss but I think they
should always be debated thank you chair
well we're having a very civilized
debate today which I'm very pleased
about and I'm allowing people to speak
uh in the chair so from one of the
Rogues I was a rogue as well in Rose
Gallery I'm going to pass you back to
Liam foreign
thank you very much I'm actually uh
relieved to hear counselor hook speaking
uh with such passion the last time I
heard her speak with such uh alacrity
was when she uh showed that we were a
pair of Pricks across the chamber
um which I fully approve of uh robust
robust debate uh I think it's desperate
though I think it's really really
desperate to go back five years to troll
up a website that I put up when I was a
private citizen when I had no intention
of standing for this Council it it had
not in my wildest dreams did I ever
think I would ever be on this Council it
was not in my intention I was a private
citizen I was I felt the victim of a
situation developing around me that
seemed wrong that nobody seemed willing
to uh to defend against that and it was
a conservative Council back then that
that the entire Ayah of that website was
launched against and I can tell you we
got commendations saying nice one from
various lib Dems including uh the the
counselor's husband
it was only until it was yes you did you
said nice one
yes you did don't sit there and lie you
said nice one and it was only when I
made a comment about Gordon that he
turned on his and that's the way it was
while it was hitting the other side
while it was hitting the Tories the lib
Dems really quite liked that website and
don't let them tell you otherwise
now in terms of what I'm meant to have
done I'm getting really fed up of the
way that this um Jessica shears story is
being
misinterpreted as if it was something
appalling I don't want to talk about
Jessica shears and I'm sure Mr shears
doesn't want to either but I don't think
I'm doing her to service by saying she's
somebody who hasn't shied away from
headlines or from photographs and the
photograph I used was supplies to her
own PR agent no no
says when I stand that counselor shall
be quiet that is all that happened Liam
it's a little bit I'm getting a little
bit personal can you please refrain from
that I am answering a personal issue
that councilor hook raised she mentioned
and I'm merely answering are we going
can we get back to the motion please
thank you I'm not entirely speaking to
the motion I'm speaking to answer that
insane things we're here to make the
motion please
please I know that all I wish to say is
this one point one point just let him
finish and then we'll go to the motion I
know there's election coming up I know
that you really want to
play the professional victim and pretend
that you've been bullied because that's
what Joseph goebbel said is the best way
of propaganda bully people was claiming
to be bullied harassed while claiming to
be harassed Roy was claiming we are are
unconstructive but it won't work
everyone knows who the bullies are yes
can I be clear at no point
we haven't
I run
those that wish to support you you
sorry counselor hook over there do you
want a quick word before I take the vote
on the motion that those risk to support
it and those that don't all right I want
to go to the vote in a second now please
I think it was Mr chairman I think
that's that's quite right that you
should do so so I'm just gesticulating
on the far side of the river
no okay right I think they're probably
only two people in the room yourself
being one in the gentleman sitting next
to you being the other who uh understand
the significance of saying
um anybody who's faced the Pontypool
front row has was famous back in the 80s
uh coming full blast at them
isn't afraid of anybody in this room
um if you could if you could face the
Ponte pool front row in full flight you
can probably face anybody in this room
and I had no fear of anybody in this
room let me assure you
uh a lot has been said this morning and
clearly a number of um
rashes and sores are being reopened
perhaps unnecessarily but I think I
should throw in my three penith as a
consequence of being mentioned under
some of the things that have been said
this morning I was leader if members
recall for I don't know 60 18 months or
so at the beginning of this
Administration it's quite clear
references be made to um
the the the file vile has got the same
letters as evil incidentally I just draw
that to members attention
um but the vile webpage that was put up
properly as councilor Malone says well
before the the election but was still in
place for a long time after the election
despite the fact that it was uh asked to
be removed and wasn't I just add one
little bit of new information as it were
to all that has been said this morning
um
while leader I received in my office at
least double figures of Junior
and uh intermediate officers complaining
to me about the bullying and harassment
of two members of the Newton says no
group
I sympathize with them and I told them
that the methodology would be to
progress any complaints via their lead
officer or the header department and and
that was the advice given I sympathized
one of those at least one of those
officers was in tears
complaining bitterly about the treatment
received at the hands of
counselor's door and councilor's Malone
that is for the record I put that on
record
officers perceived that they were being
bullied and harassed and if people
officers or others receive that to be
the case then those allegations need to
be taken seriously
now going back a long time as a junior
teacher I was given advice
by
what I suppose was a mentor
he said that uh
bear in mind at all times that you win
more with sugar than you do with vinegar
and sadly far too much vinegar has been
spilled in the last four years
much of that
much of that due to two councilors who
I've already named
it's very sad that they do not see
neither do their supporters see the bile
and the vileness that has come from
their mouths and their actions and their
stance on so many different issues this
Authority May well have done things
incorrectly procedurally incorrectly I
Ally myself very strongly to the
apologies that have been given I
apologize if there is any error
whatsoever on my part I don't believe
there was but be that as it may it's not
a debating point for the moment
I very much regret that anybody feels
that their free speech has been impacted
and I very much regret the the comments
that have been coming forward
um over the weeks and months
towards officers uh who by and large are
not in a position to reply I think it
must be fundamentally wrong to attack
people who do not have the ability to
reply to harass and Bully those who
cannot respond that is what NSN have
been doing that is what the public need
to know in my opinion they're unfit for
public office but that's a matter of
debate and that's a matter for the
electorate to decide
I rest my case let's have more sugar
let's have less vinegar let's try and
work together because we should be
working for the common good of the
people of this district and quite
clearly the negativity that has come
from a certain quarter does not help
that one iota
they failed they failed and now they're
changing their name to avoid that
failure thank you
right you have the right Council doors
to sum up as a motion and then after
you've spoken I'm hearing nothing more
than going to the vote right you've got
your chance to say uh yes I'm I'm using
my right to reply on the various points
of the raised and summing up in the
motion so I I agree uh with with uh well
I appreciate cancer Jackie Hill's
comments and note that the news says no
website was was uh satirical and
hard-hitting uh it was written by
private individual it did predate uh as
being counselors and probably is the
sole reason that the standards
proceedings started it was it was
started to settle the personal score in
my opinion if uh if we go to count as
the Boulevard's point where he suggested
uh that access was gained into the uh
into the building using my pass uh I I'd
ask councilor believe in to work to look
at the the ombudsman's reports and see
whether any complaint was raised about
that and whether that formed any part of
the complaints against me because he
didn't and the reason that people wanted
to get into that building that day and
these are notes from the ombudsman's
investigator I'm grateful for you
sharing with me the emails sent to you
on the 24th of September 2019 where you
asked the council to make a climate
change briefing open to the public I
agree that these show that you did not
receive the reasoned explanation why the
council briefing could not be made open
to the public we have considered and
therefore not to address this matter in
their poor because it would risk losing
focus so that's that Point's taken the
in terms of the managing directors
points of uh if it's criminal take it to
the police what the Ombudsman said in
his report he didn't say it was criminal
did he he said you acted contrary to the
law uh and and our view is that
misconduct in public office has taken
place those are civil cases so uh I
think it might be fair to suggest that
we are looking at recourse on that front
in terms of councilor Swain's Point
saying that malab ministration didn't
feature in the ombudsman's report
clearly he didn't read the definitions
because in the definitions it says where
I use the word folds it either means
service non-delivery or mal
Administration therefore throughout the
report the word fault means Mal
Administration in the intense when he
wasn't talking about a service delivery
in terms of free speech and uh and and
everyone requiring that and and I'm
delighted actually the only good thing
that came out today is uh is that we had
the debate and and I I commend people
for for for actually uh allowing that
debate to happen but it seems a bit uh a
bit Rich for councilors to suggest that
free speech is uh is is what we have
when uh when when they constantly uh
suggest that we talk over people I don't
think there's only one time where we've
where we've stood up and and suggested
that a counselor should not be heard
and uh and that's happened on multiple
occasions
in terms of behavior
uh I I know councilor Gordon hoax points
where he made some various serious
allegations about bullying and
harassment none of those there were no
complaints made against me the local
government or Muslims said there were no
complaints
um and uh in the terms of councilor
Malone his uh his position is exactly
the same there are no complaints raised
against him I I would invite anyone to
uh to to bring those forward if they
indeed existed but uh I don't believe
they do what does exist is that we were
subject to criminal harassment that that
was dealt with by the police he was
taken to the police and they did speak
to the individual involved and warned
him not to do it again the the failure
of this Council was not to do anything
about it themselves so summing up we do
have systemic failings I do know that in
the report you had 10 points and you
were so concerned by the report you've
decided to write to the Secretary of
State to suggest maybe the Ombudsman
report is so wide reaching that it
affects all of the counties all of the
councils around the country but what you
haven't managed to do is a little bit of
introspectiveness is to think that if
it's if it affects councils around the
country then maybe it affects other
cases and other other conducts that have
happened and other procedural failings
that have happened within this Council
within this tenure uh there is a long
list I will send them out there will be
evidence and if this Council doesn't do
anything about it then they will be
subject to a civil claim against this
Council and the individual's concerned
thank you
right thank you for that right go to the
vote those in favor of the motion please
for those against the motion
the Motions failed any extensions
right we moved to the final uh
sorry what's wrong
no there's counseling questions and
there's none
all right
so uh on on that note that concludes a
meeting and I declare the meeting close
thank you
[Music]